time for jeopardy warm up we get to see
which of our contestants knows the most
about las vegas
our contestants tonight it's all the
gentleman in the house brian loftus
john treach i'm not sure what john's
doing hi john um right
you will have 15 seconds to answer okay
guys so
let's get started contestants let's show
you what your clue is we've got a warm
weekend right
no doubt many of you are maybe going to
be cooling off at the lake so that's a
hint
here is tonight's clue developers broke
ground on lake las vegas
in this year which year was it they
broke ground
not the year that the rights were
purchased when they put shovels in
when they broke yeah when shovels hit
the dirt
oh just gonna have to take a stab at it
you really are well 15 seconds guys
yeah um
all right okay i think time's up ted did
a lot of hmm
so let's go to ted
still is no no
2001 no no go farther back brian how'd
you do if i may say the land and water
rights were purchased in the 1960s
but i believe the shovels went in in the
mid 90s oh that's pretty close because i
know you were there this weekend i was
but that is incorrect
is it how close are we you're you're
you're warm
oh johnny johnny it looks new water
looks good
that's when johnny was born guys here's
our answer
what is it 1987. wow is the year they
broke ground that's
for lake lost i could have sworn it was
in 90s sorry but i am wrong
time just goes by like that no winners
tonight no bragging rights
but you're all winners on our heart
thanks for joining us tonight we'll see
you back
at 11 o'clock